Ok. Type or do you choose the second of march no they don't need three.
Home in sydney and jones so it is in leeds more we're doing a two way.
Joint going to give you start introducing who you are and.
When you first came to nimbin urn how you describe how you feeling. Well. My name's john. And presently. I guess.
Rainforest conservationist and. Philosopher. Are often in august nine hundred seventy three.
Are been living in england for five years and i was on my way back to australia.
Travelling for about nine months out of the land through asia. Meditating in india and nepal studying meditation.
And i never heard of newman. Or the aquarius festival. Back in august. And then a good friend of mine carol elliott.
Who's. You know a pretty important figure i think in the nimbin story carol elliott norman stand. When i got to see me.
With my wife gretta.
They said oh you've got to go up to nimbin and we've got a place that you can stay at on crofton's route.
So we drove straight up we didn't like sydney too much we drove straight up and. Well it's been here ever since.
Can you tell us about those early does. In how you started out. Well. I remember.
Carolyn norman saying when you get to nimbin. Just go to the rainbow cafe and ask for jim.
And i thought you know i just thought of an australian cafe
and i thought oh that's an unusual name for a cafe the right. And we got to nimbin and.
There was the rainbow exactly where it is now and. We got there just in time for dinner which was a commune all male.
Around. One long table and. Basically our. I realized the whole of the. New settler community in that region.
Was sitting around that table that not you know that everyone had gone back from the festival
when there was just a handful of people maybe twenty or thirty people. Left after the festival and.
They're all sitting around that table. So it's grown a lot since then. So you do so yourself was part of that.
Back to the earth movement. You know to get back to. You know starting your own port building your own who.
Well i quickly came to see myself that way that wasn't my original intention in going up there originally i just moved
to the country and. I had you know.
Some interesting communities i'd been part of i kind of abortive attempted a community in northern california a couple
of years previously that on the last a few months. But i had. You know i had time to bargo.
Create my first garden which was in a spiral and. You know i would. But quickly.
I came to you know be very much part of that movement and.
I was part of the original group of shareholders in the dream that. Of coordination cooperatives that.
Then went on to become the community a town of all falls and grettir and i bought shares in that. Before.
You know there was any land or anything like that we just bought shares in that dream and.
But i myself was looking for a more spiritual community. So i want to.
You know i've been meditating in india and nepal as i say
and as soon as we arrived in australia we made contact with an english. Buddhist monk he was. You know.
Wearing tar i put a strobe scald who was teaching meditation at the chinese buddhist society in dixon street in sydney
and we invited him up and. He did.
The first meditation retreats i think it was still in seventy three or maybe seventy four. We organized maybe.
Are over the next couple of years five or six. Meditation retreats for him which. I think you know.
Had quite a profound influence on the direction of that community most of the people who were up there at that time.
Took part in one or more of those retreats. And so. I was looking for a more cohesive.
Integrated like minded community of people who are committed to.
Personal and spiritual growth and coordination cooperative intangible we're always a little bit too kind of crazy
and walled for my own tastes. At that time. And. So you're not in seventy five.
Dominant which is a community into a creek road.
That had actually started before the aquarius festival i bought that land i think in seventy one or seventy two and.
The land stretch from training a creek up to wallace road on the. Reach that separates a creek from tunnel creek and.
Dominant addai knighted a section of their land on top of that ridge for the dream that i had had
and that i shared with them of the meditation santa. And in nine hundred seventy far.
Several of us began to build up their build a shed in seventy farve and.
Started to build the foundations for meditation set up.
And then later in seventy five i went back to india again for more meditation and to spend some time with a teacher.
A woman called. Who also came back and forth. Teaching.
In australia and up in the newman area a few times and the years after that. And at that time. In dallas.
In the himalayas. While i was there to spend some time with the miller and.
Norman standout and carol elliott who started birth and beyond. You name been. Birthing.
Midwife so i guess that i that i you know i met to be with him a lot. And we also met another.
Tabu just monk an englishman. Whose name now is christopher to miss and he's quite a famous.
Progressive meditation teacher who lives in england now and he's no longer a monk but. He was in.
Carolyn norman we're doing a meditation retreat with him and. A whole bunch of young westerners were there.
So i went looking for carolyn norman. Walking up to sort of this beautiful mountain.
And i came around the turn of the mountain and there was this little. Char shop. You know like a little tea shop.
Called the todd man's do a lot of the looking. You know. Plain of the ganges. Many thousands of feet below.
And there's a whole bunch of young. Westerners there americans new zealanders australians.
Sitting around drinking coffee and eating sweet cakes from this meditation retreat. And i sat down with them.
And within five minutes. We had agreed that.
You know whole bunch of them were coming over to help build this meditation center and that we're going to.
Then look for a piece of land near bar to bar and. To grow our food and build their houses and.
That we'd be caretakers of the meditation center. And that was what actually happened so.
Within about ten minutes of that meeting the next. I guess. At least the next five years of model off.
Were pretty well. Laid out on a map and. What we discussed there was exactly what happened.
Christopher came to australia a few months later. Maybe about maybe nearly a year later.
To lead the first meditation retreat at this meditation center that we had built in the mean time and.
The participants in those actually three retreats and. Maybe about fifty participants in. H.
So out of those hundred fifty people we found twenty who wanted to share that dream of a spiritual community.
And we each put in a thousand bucks and. So. That was in. Seventy five seventy six and. Basically up until the creek.
Action in seventy nine. That was my last there. My son was born a his name is buddy. He's fifteen now and.
He was the first child born on that farm so he was named after it and. We build our own houses and you know.
Kids grew organic fruit and veggies and stuff and. Lived a very pure and beautiful life there.
Tell us about some of the. The rules. Of body farm some of the ethics. Well it was a very very highly ethical.
Society we live by the buddhist precepts of killing. Stealing lawing. Drugs or alcohol. And no sexual misconduct.
I mean you know. Sexual conduct it. Hurt anyone and. We didn't keep any animals are other domestic animals or.
You know a lot of stock.
We just want didn't want to have any fences we just wanted to live with the animals from the bush and.
We didn't want any dogs or cats getting into the bush. And we had a forest management policy which left.
Ninety five percent of the. Hundred sixty acres that we bought. It was left as bush.
And the only areas that we cleared were areas that had previously been cleared. You know i saw about.
Maybe about ten percent of the land. About sixteen acres i'd say maximum.
We maintained for a buildings near agriculture. We looked after each other and shared. Most of our things in.
Common we shared all of our mode of eagles at in those early days for instance and.
We had a calming all male every day we cooked for each other and. You know i just looked after each other there was no.
Doors necessary on the buildings now and you know. It was totally safe place to have kids and we were also you know.
Very interested in social action. This was our style of buddhism was. What you might call. Engaged. Buddhism and.
We were involved in the social issues of those days especially the home birth. Movement which was.
Illegal and we you know participated in those illegal. Births we felt that it was.
Everybody's right to take birth and death and. These things back.
Back from or thora jesus and back into our own hands and.
It's kind of a bit on real now looking back on it you know like everything's changed so much since those days
but it was a very beautiful time. We built sixteen. Illegal. On this place.
Multiple occupancy wasn't allowed then in fact. It was partly the court cases.
The sixteen demolition orders that were put on two buildings that were part of the. You know. Part of the trigger.
You know or the part of the whole thing that created multiple occupancy in new south wales.
Looking back on those terms. To you.
Do you think it's too hard on you so so far no not at all i mean if we were to try
and do that from a sense of sacrifice or.
You know or just a sense of duty or anything like that it would have been terribly difficult.
But it was totally passionate desire you know we were following our bliss erik's to see. And i can't think that.
Any of us have ever been happier since then do you know i've had things change and. Times change we were on a wife.
You know. And when you're on a wave it's easy just catch the wife and. You stay on it but.
If you have to swim in the same direction it's a different matter. You know. We're on a wife and it was crying.
There's no sense of fear in fact that a lot of those the level of sharing and.
Stuff that was happening then isn't still happening nobody.
Well i mean it's easy to get into that you know like idealising the past or something like that but it's.
I don't think it's a sense of failure it's a birdie farm is an incredibly beautiful place now
and in fact i'm living there again. I've been away for quite some years but i've moved back there again and.
I think it's fantastic. And the fact that there's only one communal meal or two a week now and the fact that.
People don't share their cars anymore because it was just such a hassle maintaining. You know it's shared. Vehicles.
And you know other things that's another thing at the beginning was that now on
and there are buildings that anyone who build a building on the land. It belong to the land so that you know.
If you left. You just. It was left there for someone else you know and. So there's no buying or selling of buildings.
That's kind of changed a little bit i mean you know. Not. Not totally but you know.
Things you know things change people get older and. I think it's still great. What about the strain on relationships.
Plus what my body found in those so we go. Well i don't think i can remember anything anything. Particular you know.
I mean.
I don't think that there was such a strain on relationships i think that there's a huge strain on relationships in a
nuclear family situation where. The only people that you have that you're close to. You know.
You know like three or four people and then. With them they're on top of you all the time.
Place like body farm all of the kids had. You know. A dozen. You know people that they laughed and.
Held in were close to and if your parents were off the air. It just didn't matter so much. You know and.
Also there was you know levels of sharing and. Communion and intimacy that i think.
You know that that's how we're meant to live really you know that's how we.
That's that's how our tribes were for hundreds of thousands of years and.
I think it's a terrible strain to try and live any other way.
Can you tell us about the development of the growing lobby of the rainforest a promotion center.
And where you fit into that. Well. That goes back to august seventy nine when you know a creek blew up and.
This was a much more just start again and. To make it a statement.
Back in well back in nine hundred seventy nine in august. I went to the channon market which is a monthly. Craft and.
Produce market down the chan and just nearby. And.
Some of their neighbors from down in the valley a creek appealed for help.
They'd been struggling for farve years to try and stop the forestry commission from logging the end of that valley.
Rainforest down there and they had the forestry commission coming in the following day with bulldozers
and they wanted to help to do a blockade and. That seemed very you know.
Far away from me from what i was interested in i was interested in meditation and.
Organic gardening and stuff but somehow. The next day along with.
I think just about everyone from body farm i found myself down there with a few hundred people.
And we did this blockade and. It was incredible and.
Somehow or other a lot of people were very very moved their lives were moved by that but manof was totally transformed.
And in fact within two years. It had pulled me off. Entirely.
But it started more slowly than that and i was sort of back and forth. But you know when i was in the right.
Forest i heard it. Screaming. You know.
And i heard screaming for help and over the next couple of years at a creek
and later on in the campaign for the not kept range.
And the rainforest of new south wales i became more and more modern life and the loss of the rainforest became
and meshed. So in.
Nine hundred ninety one having learned about the plight of the rainforests in many other countries and.
Empowered bar as success in really being able to do something. You know. Moving from a situation.
In august seventy nine.
Where most people had never even heard of rainforests let alone knew their significance to eighty two
when the rann government made the historic decision to protect the rainforest of new south wales.
We felt incredibly empowered.
That ordinary people who didn't have any particular training or background could really do something.
And we've also learnt that the rainforests of the world were threatened that. They contained.
More than fifty percent of the world's. Species of plants and animals.
And that at the current rates of destruction they would be utterly and within our own life time.
And that this would be.
Unprecedented in the history of the world and also that many scientists warn that if we allowed this to happen.
The last support systems of the earth would be destroyed and complex life would vanish from the earth.
Within a few human generations. So.
We also discovered in writing to groups around the world that there wasn't a single group at that time.
That had the world's rainforests on its agenda. So that's when we started the rainforest information sandor in lismore.
And began. Networking and trying to create a network around the world. To work on far as problems in.
You know indonesia and brazil in malaysia or a new guinea.
And other countries where are the kind of consciousness that we had developed. Didn't exist as yet.
And meanwhile we were still very. Are active. Issues. In australia. Right forest issues from the franklin where.
About ten
or fifteen of us from the lismore area were invited down by the wilderness society to help set up their blockade of the
franklin river in i.e. Three.
And then also up to the daintree where most of the people at the daintree protest also came from the.
You know the from the name been. It's rainy creek lease more area and.
But not only rain forest issues in nineteen eighty we did.
Blockades at middle had in the mid north coast of new south wales to stop a sand mining operation there.
And also we were very involved in the pine gap and. A lot of the women were involved in the women's.
Actions in those days. The warship. Actions trying to stop the nuclear power and american warships.
From entering australian waters and so on i guess there's traditionally been a lot of resentment i guess. Because of.
Because of the fact that there's been a lot of people at the forefront of those movements from the nimbin bar north
coast area. Do you have any apologies for that old. Bar now i mean i just think people are sour and grateful. You know.
I mean you look at the opinion polls and it's.
Shows that ninety percent of everyone thinks that we need an environmental thing and so on and so on and.
No one really acknowledges where the where the. You know where the lead you know. From that came from and.
I know that it's unpopular and that makes me.
You know i have all the more admiration for the people that did it he was this totally thankless task where people were
abused and vilified for waking everybody up. You know.
It's like people want to stay asleep people would rather choke to death on their own vomit in their sleep
and wake up are enough. So i don't feel apologetic at all as you can hear. Ok what about the role of the.
Grown extremists. And what about the term. Worries do you do this with the.
Oh well i mean i don't you know i'm not sort of quite romantic like that myself to you know not
but i can i get is that again a much better statement. Well. I mean i don't.
I don't associate myself and think of myself as a as a rainbow warrior or anything romantic like that.
But i am a green extremist and. I guess i am a rainbow warrior i mean if that. Meaning.
Has you know if that word has any meaning and. I think that i'm surrounded by.
Green extremists and rainbow warriors here. The local. Forest. Protection society ha ha so-called. You know.
The lawyers wives and the rest. That i started a group called raw age and it's something like.
Stands for something like rage against green extremists or something like that so the rainforest information center.
Printed these t.
Shirts with green extremists across the front and huge letters
and it's a most popular autumn you see them everywhere and here. We sell hundreds of.
You know people are proud to be green extremists. Can you tell us a bit about your spiritual journey and.
You're developing your relationship with the rainforest and then that. That sort of.
Well you know this developed slowly from those years but so i don't argue yes that i can feel so much.
My spiritual journey. Changed from a buddhist perspective to. What i would call deep ecology of those years.
In the buddhist perspective. Really mind and spirit and the inner life of human beings is primary.
But it quickly became clear to me in the rainforest. That my body and my mind.
Had evolved within these very forests over the last hundred fifty million years ago when the first.
Flowering plants in the world were evolving. In gone on a land of a giant soup of.
On and to include south america and australia and antarctica. Covered in rainforests.
The place that's now cape tribulation the first flowering plants the.
Angiosperms were developing my insistence was some kind of little rodent. Scurrying around.
You know trying to get out from under the dinosaurs one hundred thirty million years ago. Now. Since that time.
My body and my mind. Have evolved to where i am now and. To try and separate. The spiritual life from that.
Incredible miracle of that evolution it seems to me is a very few tall task and also a dangerous one because.
As a result of the way that we.
Despise nature and think of the earth as just dirt and having no soul having no intelligence and. Life.
And by denying our connection with that i mean.
If we understand our own evolution then we realize that we are just like a leaf. On the tree of life.
And that if we are a law if then it's only because the tree is alive.
And if we are intelligent it's only part of a tiny fragment of the intelligence of the tree.
So he is the earth which holds. Maybe ten million species of plants and animals in incredible.
Symbiosis and cooperation and partnership and we are one of those. How can we call that.
You know how can we think of that as being dead heck and we think of that as having no soul. So very much.
My spiritual journey became one of surrendering to the body of which i am just one cell the body of god the living.
Earth and. Finding that it's very easy to read. Receive instruction and meaning from our life from that that.
In the same way as. You know my heart beats and.
You know my lungs work and my fingernails grow you know
and i all grow if i cooperate in order to create the integration that is this body. So i feel that we humans.
If we will let go of their futile. Kind of self-interest with a small s. and Recognize that our own self interest.
Can't be. Other than the interests of the earth of which. We are just a tiny fragment. You know. Then.
You know what once we understand that then it's very easy for our lives.
To fall back into harmony again with the earth. In the way that.
Of course our ancestors life must have been in harmony. Or they wouldn't have survived for a minute.
You look around at every tree and every plant every animal.
And it lives in harmony with the earth it doesn't struggle against the earth.
And it resists receives its instructions for the earth it knows how to feed itself how to breathe how to reproduce
itself. But we in our arrogance. Thinking ourselves superior tonight. Have kind of. Shut ourselves off from that.
But the good news is that all that we have to do is let go of that arrogance and recognize that we are merely.
Part of the earth. Merely miraculously. Part of the earth.
And then we too can fall back into harmony with the earth again and. It's only by doing this our belief that.
Rice that our species. And indeed complex life at all will be supported on the earth.
We are the last generation of human beings that will be in a position to make that decision. It's clear from.
David suzuki. Says that we have less than ten years before.
The damage to the last support systems reaches the point of no return. The damage to the air and the water in the soil.
The poisoning of the earth these. These things will reach a point of no return. Very very soon. And that.
Unless we take responsibility for. You know. Caring for the earth. Correctly. Living correctly on the earth.
Our children will get a chance and no future generation of humans will have a chance because it'll be too light.
But that can't come from a sense of sacrifice or a sense of duty as long as we feel separate from nature
and think that. You know it that we have to somehow. Protect this thing.
The environment you know something over their spirit separ. From us then we're doomed to failure.
It's only when we realize that we are not the environment.
That every breath we take connects us to the earth every drop of water or food.
That passes into our body connects us to the earth we are connected.
It's just that we ignore that connection
and we define ourselves as purely spiritual beings whatever that might mean you know once we once we once we realize
that we are part of the earth then this spiritual thing is actually very down to earth anyone who wants to prove this
to themselves only has to hold their breath. For three minutes. You know.
Anyone holding their breath for three minutes will quickly realize what i'm talking about. We can call it.
The atmosphere and think that it's over there
and that it's not really in their self interest to protect it you know stop the c.f.c.'s and so on do you know.
But it's not the atmosphere it's part of our own body that we're talking about. And by projecting it. Out there.
We're destroying ourselves and we're destroying the earth once we acknowledge that it's part of us.
Then there's dissect for us necessary in order to protect it. You know if someone's.
Soaring our leg off we don't sort of say look i'm too busy to protect it. We know it's part of us and you know.
We just do whatever we have to do. So anyway that's my. Spiritual position i guess. I guess the detractors of the.
Be occurring
or duals who would say that people who moved to the newman area twenty years ago were saying the same things then.
We only heard. You know. Less than ten years left but look we're you know we're still here and.
It hasn't happened but the. Stuff doesn't happen. Well. So. I think it has happened. But.
I mean you know i look around and you look at what's happening to the world. It's you know it's just a tragedy.
You know. But you know the poisoning of the air and the oceans and. The quality of life to tearing and sour.
But i'm personally not saying that it is going to happen in ten years myself. I'm quoting david suzuki who says that.
I myself feel that the earth has. More resilience than that. But the fact that this is coming very very soon.
I don't think that there's any doubt about that.
We're losing an average of more than two hundred species every day this can't go on there's a finite.
You know there's there's. There's there's only so much that the earth can take. I think everybody knows this anyway.
You know this i don't think many people would say that anymore i think most people would.
If they really were honest with themselves realize that this can't go on. Can you tell us a bit about the why that you.
Explored.
The earth by spirituality i'm thinking of the council of all beings which was something that you to go to
and you co-wrote a book called thinking like a man. Can you expand on some of themes of. Well you know.
This deep ecology philosophy which of karn of been expanding.
You know it was very satisfying but i realized that it didn't change anything that we could have these are do years.
But it was still terribly difficult to change our behavior. And as i looked into that i was sorry. Ok.
So the castle of all beings was an attempt to bring. Deep ecology to life to actually change our behavior and.
One of the things that i realized. As i was studying this problem is.
Of how is it that we human beings can be so stupid as to soar off the very branch that we ourselves are sitting on i
mean. Why do we do we want to commit suicide what are we doing. How come it's so difficult to change.
And i realize that. We modern humans are the first. Civilization. In the history of the world.
To dispense with the rituals and ceremonies that. All other peoples. Have and still do. Practice which.
Acknowledge and nurture that interconnectedness between human. Things in the rest of the earth community.
That it seems is that sense of interconnectedness which all other species.
Have you know i mean baboons and flowers never forget that they are part of the earth. You know never occurs to them.
So we humans are the first ones to think that we might be something special something superior something different and.
The way that we've you know remained connected to the earth and remained part of the great symphony
and not just got lost in our own ideas and thoughts. Was with these ceremonies in these rituals and.
So the council of all beings. Is a modern version of this it's a way in which. Through a couple of days of.
Ceremony and ritual and. And communion with each other we can reestablish. Not the idea of.
Deep ecology but leaving experience of deep ecology the living experience that the earth is my body and.
Once i feel that the earth is my body it becomes much much simpler. To defend the earth because it's.
I'm no longer defending. Something outside myself and so it's like. It wasn't the right. It wasn't me.
As a separate being defending the rainforest. The environment or i became. That part of the rainforest.
That was acting in its own self-defense and of course self-defense. Is much much easier it doesn't require any great.
And i believe he or any great. You know. Special qualities anybody can defend themselves.
Can you tell us a bit about what happens during those three those in the crowd who were all brings what people actually
do get to come around a bit. Well. First of all i'd have to say that the council of all beings can consist of all.